Stanford Law's Equity Dean is booted out
after uh stoking woke students rude
protest at a conservative judge who's
invited to give a talk so a Stanford
Dean who was slammed for letting
students tackle a conservative federal
judge before berating him herself has
left her role basically what happened
was this judge came to speak on campus
the students protested he went to
basically explain that it was
unacceptable that it was impossible to
hear him because he was being spoken
over and she went on to uh berate him so
she has decided that she's going to be
leaving her role as assistant Dean for
diversity equity and inclusion what are
they going to do without her at Stanford
law school to pursue another opportunity
the law school said in an email to its
students Thursday what do you guys think
about this story do you think that they
have more Dei coordinators at that
school do you think she was the only one
or do you think Stanford has a couple
well I don't know if you know this but
there is a notorious shortage of Dei
Professionals in this country we
actually might run out of them which is
very frightening it is scary because who
keeps the country running how do we get
keep any of this going without them I
mean there are so many things to
critique about the story first off uh
let's let's be glad to see the end of
administrative blow in in universities
uh famously that's that's terrible for
any any function University this
particular story just makes me laugh
we're talking about a little bit
beforehand uh but the fact that you know
this this event was it was on March 9th
and this uh Trump appointed federal
judge Kyle Duncan came to speak he was
invited there by the federal Society uh
he gets shouted down he asked us for an
administrator she comes in and is
berating him saying that you know he's
hurtful and he's tearing this Society
Community apart disenfranchising student
rights right but then afterwards I hate
this in French but then afterwards a
couple students for the wrote for the
Stanford uh review saying she sent out
an email beforehand engineering chaos
she came in with prepared remarks they
call I really appreciate this from the
students they called Cynthiana said you
say you value Free Speech then you need
to hold this person accountable because
she intentionally went against it now of
course this battle continued to be
public uh and uh Steinbach the woman
involved wrote her own op-ed that the
Wall Street Journal published being like
I was just there to de-escalate of
course I don't know what happened but it
could not have been that I was at all
inciting this uh and so you get these
conflicting accounts and I find this
deeply interesting she said that she was
there to represent the student voices so
they could stop shouting which means
that like she came in with it started
shouting yeah well well firstly of
course she was just trying to calm
things down that's what a Dei officer
does as a University at a university
providing people by their identity at
all also I love this excuse I love this
excuse this is Golder this is like such
an incredible attempt at spin I almost
admire it when all the students were
heckling this person and I went up there
and began heckling them it's because I
was trying to stop the students from
doing it I was trying to give them an
outlet this is what I have begun to call
Outlet Theory basically what left-wing
people will try to do to justify the
normalization of bad behavior is they'll
say this bad thing is going to happen
anyway so we need to give it an outlet
and of course what you end up doing is
encouraging it to continue to happen and
you get more of it and I think it's not
surprising that this is the excuse you
went with because it actually fits into
the framework of a left-wing worldview
and the excuses they usually make no no
the only reason I was doing bad thing is
because I wanted to give bad thing an
outlet because I'm actually against that
thing on some level it's totally
incoherent well it's funny that she's
diversity and inclusion and she seemed
to lack both of those as her role right
I mean there was no diversity in terms
of intellectual diversity and what about
inclusion you know whatever happened
it's funny how you know when I was a kid
they would say well if you don't like it
turn off the channel or if you don't
like it don't listen to that album and
now it's the right saying that if you
don't want to go listen to this judge
just don't go to the lecture that is not
allowed a surprise in a class that you
had to be in right this was an event
organized by Society for him to come to
that everyone probably knew it was going
to be this guy which is what made them
want to go there right and I'm not
against the concept of protesting it
just makes me crazy that the idea is
that this person had to be completely
shouted down rather than this
institution supposed to be about
learning and growth and having your
ideas challenged and this is
manufactured protesting because yeah
we're all pretty smart but the exception
of this one name another judge
right like name another not Supreme
Court I can name them name a federal
judge I bet you none of us really could
so what college student is like you're
telling me judge Duncan Kyle is no like
this isn't a name that is like it's
hilarious it's all manufactured because
he was appointed by Trump
and I will say especially when you're in
college like who's actually reading
Flyers you know like I certainly wasn't
them or going to this someone
manufactured this crisis and got all the
kids whipped up and now the kids are all
in a frenzy which is sad how much of
lemming the college students can become
so it's interesting then that of course
the students point out that Steinbach
this this Dei administrator
send out an email about this event it's
almost like maybe she was interested in
there being a protest so she could have
a nice Bible come down yeah
well I will say I I think what I found
the most interesting about the story
because it's played out over a couple
months is that uh at least two federal
judges said we're adding Stanford to our
uh no hire list we will not take clerks
from Stanford law which means that every
student at Stanford is affected by this
of course I assume they're conservative
out there at Stanford law I hope you're
doing well uh but it comes in the heels
of a different similar event at Yale law
school so there are now a stack of law
schools that there are Judges and I
think this is great they're saying I
will not hire from your school I do not
like your school and your student body's
uh uh stance on free speech and
diversity and I do not like the way
you're treating conservatives that's
unacceptable to me you would not you
would not be a good fit for my office
and again
I think these these small changes this
school district taking a stance these
judges saying like we won't tolerate it
of course some people suffer in the
crosshairs I'm sure the young
conservatives yeah and Stamper are like
well dang man yeah but on the other hand
good for the judges for doing something
and not sitting around being like well
we can't get involved yes you know this
that meal push back if they're going to
try to use their leverage against you to
undermine Civil Society you got to push
back Daniel you mentioned something
earlier how the left always used to say
if you don't like it you can change the
channel and how they're hypocritical for
not sticking to that but I think what
you're missing is what they were saying
is if you don't like it you can change
the channel those are the options that
you have when I don't like it you change
the channel yeah it's always been about
dominance right evil calls for tolerance
until it's in charge and then it demands
your submission yeah remember when the
riots were happening in the Summer of
Love And even you can go back further
even in the the Trump inauguration of
2017 to go off your point Sheamus when a
lot of Mayors said look we're just
giving them space to protest and you're
like well you're letting them Burn the
City down we're just giving them space
to protest and that's what this was that
was what this diversity the EI
coordinator was saying I am just giving
them a platform to express their ideas
and I partook of it because I wanted to
try to control the violence and again if
you give people a space to do if you
give bad people a space to commit bad
acts they will commit bad acts well and
this is part of what's so uh hilarious
just about how quickly they expose
themselves as complete and total
unprincipled Hypocrites I remember
during the 2020 riots there were two
things I kept hearing from left-wing
individuals
first thing rioting is the language yes
okay so that's one quote let's all just
keep in mind that's beautiful yeah isn't
that thank you doesn't that just touch
your heart poetry and then there was a
second point that they kept making
repeatedly I saw this all over Twitter I
saw left-wing people I knew saying this
they were going well you know
conservatives claim the point of you
know 2A is to like fight back against
tyranny and why aren't they helping us
as we are here trying to fight back
against tyranny
so literally by the way calling for
Insurrection right and then
just a few months later on January 6th
when we had conservatives rioting well
all of a sudden the response was to make
sure they were as unheard as possible
on social media banned Donald Trump ban
Donald Trump the sitting president of
the United States from one of the
largest communication Platforms in the
world you're gonna tell me you thought
writing was the language of the unheard
and the way you get rioting is by
silencing people and then you silenced
the person you believe not stopping it
exactly who you believe is the
figurehead in in the voice of the people
who were rioting and then all of a
sudden Insurrection became a bad thing
that we weren't supposed to be in favor
of and weren't supposed to tolerate and
we're supposed to be very against
meanwhile just a few months ago on May
29th of 2021 left-wing radicals
surrounded the White House broke down
the barrier forced the president of the
United States and his family into the
presidential bunker in the entire media
laughed about it and said it was so mean
that Donald Trump cleared those
protesters out of there before before
they tried to burn down Saint John's
well you're forgetting the most
important verse in uh the modern
religion which is uh it's okay when we
do it progressives 23 16. yeah that's
right that's exactly right you don't
understand yes
because we are on a moral High Ground
right so when we say these people are
writing because they're unheard we are
correct and when we're saying you guys
are riding because you're evil and the
devil we are also right there's no
arguing there because there's no
consistent logic there's no consistent
application of values yeah thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time